hi the the title of my talk is kind of
nondescript programming with math this
is because when I got the invitation I
was supposed like half a year ago or so
you know I I had to come up with a title
and some kind of description and I
wasn't sure what I would be interested
in right you know like at this I I keep
changing my my interest so I didn't know
what what would be my current interest
and I knew it would be mathematical some
somewhat related to mathematics so that
was a safe bet okay but what I'm and
what I'm going to talk about will be
related to mathematics but it will be
mathematics of type theory okay so we'll
be talking about type theory and type
theory is is really interesting to me
and every time I go to a conference I
try to talk to people who who don't like
types who like programming JavaScript or
all these languages that are weakly
typed trying to find out why would
anyone wants to use the language that
doesn't have types right so my next
slide why people hate types and and
there are actually good reasons to hate
types okay so so I will be like playing
devil's advocate right now the main
reason why types are a problem is that
types limit our ability to reuse code
right we when we write code like if you
went to the previous talk by Chris he
gave lots of examples of of code in
which types were really really useful
but these were all
concrete examples right but there is
this this other side of the coin when
people are trying to write libraries
right and in libraries you want to write
code that's reusable or you write some
code and you decide okay I want to be
more general than this right and I'm
stuck with this particular type how do I
generalize over types so this is a huge
problem and in most languages generic
code is really hard to write right it's
it's like working with with types
working on types right using types as
variables essentially requires you to
learn a different language right it's
like in C++ for instance I used to be a
C++ programmer in C++ it was really fun
because you had to learn this new
language this less than greater than
brackets you know and it's like it's a
completely different language it's a
very complicated complex language and
you have to be like a real guru in order
to program in this in this new language
and then when you make a mistake oh gosh
the the type errors are so cryptic right
I mean anybody who's seen type errors in
in template code in C++ well no so it is
really difficult to use types and when
you write reusable code and there is a
proof of this
the proof is JavaScript JavaScript has
lots of libraries it's many many more
libraries than C++ C++ is an older
language and has like every time I went
to like a C++ meeting there was always
as complain about like why don't we have
libraries to do
this or to do that like every other
languages all these libraries and c++
doesn't why doesn't it because it's
extremely hard to write libraries and
and there there are these few I I mean
fingers of one hand or two hands maybe
gurus who can write really reasonable
libraries of the quality of standard
library quality you know and it's like
there is a new addition to the standard
library every few years or so on the
other hand they have types help us with
bugs right the type checker is like this
amazing tool and it comes free with with
your compiler it detects bugs in your
code so it's I mean if somebody told you
you know you're a JavaScript programmer
you know I have this product you know
how much would you pay for it it goes
over your your program and checks it for
errors and gives you like error reports
you know how much would you pay for it
with strongly typed languages you get it
for free and then ties provides you with
some kind of documentation right I mean
in JavaScript there is a function that
takes an object and returns an object
okay what kind of object well there has
to be some kind of documentation that
says well this object has to have this
field and that field and so on and that
field has to have another field and so
on so where do you put this
documentation right you you write
comments maybe or maybe you have a
separate document or so on well types
actually provide this kind of
documentation that is checkable by the
compiler so it never goes out of you
know SEC it never goes obsolete
and it's it's actually can help you in
designing your code not not in many
languages but like the the more strongly
typed languages the more people actually
use this idea of type driven development
and in Haskell a lot of development is
that is done this way and an independent
type languages like idris you know there
is like a whole book about type driven
development and and going back to
javascript okay there are so many
libraries okay so we agree right so what
is the problem is is this inherent in in
typed languages that they have to be so
hard to use or is it is is there a
reason for this that can be overcome can
we overcome this problem so the the
let's go to the source of the problem
okay so one one source of the problem is
that most strongly typed languages and
and I'm not pointing fingers have a very
ad hoc type system that was developed
organically that started by specifying
type says you know this is how the stuff
is stored in memory okay it uses so many
bytes and these bytes are followed by
these bytes and so on so it started very
very low level and then you have
pointers right which are addresses in
memory and so on so you start with this
low level and use and then you start to
build up a more abstract type system and
and you end up with this kitchen sink of
the type system okay and and then you
try to add generic types in order to
build libraries using some kind of
generosity right you have to abstract
over types
so you add them as an afterthought like
si started without and in generic types
right you had to use macros and C++ came
didn't have anything and then they came
up with templates okay because they
wanted to write the standard template
library STL so so it was added right
then Java came and generic types you
know like let's do everything with
casting and so on void pointers casting
what what have you right and eventually
they decide okay we really need
something so let's just add on top of an
existing language without really
thinking about it from the very
beginning right and now we have some new
languages that say no no no generic
programming and and of course in a few
years from now they will have generic
programming right you can quote me on
that
okay but there is there is a good theory
okay this is what I was what I'm going
to talk about there is a good theory and
most language designers ignore this
theory because it's it's hard theory
it's not in an easy theory it's it's
like abstract mathematics okay but my
point is that without these good basics
you know if you don't have good
foundations in your language then it's
really really hard to build these higher
level abstractions that will let you
reuse code Reggie write generic code
that then can be reused so that you
don't have to reinvent the wheel every
time and when there is a systematic type
theory and it's by this Swedish guy okay
pair Martin love
if I pronounced it correctly okay so so
he's this is not such an old theory you
know I mean he's still alive and it's
not like lambda calculus right so this
this guy actually wrote a theory that's
mathematical theory but but it can be
used to describe things like algebraic
data types and and actually also
dependent types so this theory
encompasses all this all this stuff but
interestingly enough it's it's a theory
that has nothing to do with programming
I I don't think he was coming up with
type theory thinking about about
programming I don't know exactly what
the history was but it was it had more
to do with with logic with
intuitionistic logic and and the
connection between logic and programming
is was discovered later as this
propositions as types curry Howard
isomorphism which says that it's
actually the same theory that
intuitionistic logic type theory is the
same thing and in fact it's also the
same thing as category theory and I
usually talk about category theory this
time I'm not going to really talk much
about category theory but all these
ideas can be found in all three areas in
programming in category theory and in
type theory and in logic okay so that's
for sorry and of course from category
theory we know that there are these
higher-order things
higher level abstractions like Mona's
mano eights functors and so on so
generic programming for me generic
programming is really abstracting over
types you want to write code that is
typed but then you want to abstract over
some set of types and saying my code
will not will not only work for these
ties but will work for a bigger set of
types right so generic types you have to
introduce generic types so these are
like three major things that that you
have to do in order to have generic code
you have to be able to construct types
from types so we need some kind of
functions on types example the from from
C++ let's say vector vector is really a
function on types it takes type T it
creates a type vector of T right then
you can apply this function to a
particular time and you get a vector of
int or a vector of boolean's and so on
right but the the vector that you get
from the standard library is really a
function on types or a type constructor
okay so keep this in mind that this is
what what actually happens
oops
functions sometimes right in order to
define functions on types right how do
you define a function well you write the
definition of a function on the right
hand side of a definition of a function
you have some kind of expression on
types so in order to be able to
construct functions of types you have to
be able to write expressions on types ok
so then a function is is you know lambda
of some type equals expression on types
and so you need a theory of building
expressions from type not from values
but from types and this is called the
algebraic data types and then finally
the most important thing you want you
want to have these generic algorithms
and these generic algorithm are nothing
more but polymorphic functions
polymorphic functions that work on
multiple types at the same time okay so
you write one polymorphic function and
it will accept a generic type meaning it
will work for any type that this generic
type can produce and it's always in
systematic approach you know you want
you want to decompose your problem and
and then recompose the solution right so
when when you want to decompose the
problem of type theory well you have to
start with something with some primitive
things right so you have to define your
primitives then you have to define ways
of composing these primitive things
right and composing things that you
compose from primitive things and so on
so so you have this and this there is a
whole science of composing things ok and
actually there are several sciences that
are equivalent of composing things from
simpler things and they are things like
logic there's category theory and
there's type theory and no wonder they
are actually the same theory using just
different note
station because all these theories talk
about composing things from simpler
things okay so without further ado let
me introduce the unit so this is our
primitive this is the most primitive
type then you can have but let's start
with logic okay because all these types
start from logic so in logic this is
equivalent to the truth value truth tea
is always available it's like if you
want if you say something depends on
truth you know you can take this truth
from anywhere it just exists truth value
okay it has to exist in programming by
curry Howard isomorphism this is
equivalent to the type called unit in
Haskell this is like a empty pair of
parentheses a null tuple in C++ it's
it's an in Java it's wrongly kind of
called void because void should be
something that's empty and if you ask a
C++ programmer what is the type void
they will say it's an empty type no it's
not empty it has one value on there it's
a token that you assumed that exists and
you don't have to explicitly pass it
right but if this were a void type
meaning an empty set you wouldn't be
able to call a function that takes a
void because you can never generate a
value of type four which is an element
of an empty set an empty set is empty
they would never be able to call it so
it's really unit okay and in set theory
set theory is very useful because set
theory provides this this model for for
all these types I mean the type theories
is completely abstract but it has a
model it's like okay for every type I
can I can
find something in type fear in set
theory that corresponds to it in this
case it's a it's a singleton set a
singleton set contains just one element
all singleton sets are isomorphic so
it's just pick one singleton set has one
element and that's it
but in type theory which is which is
abstract every type is defined by
introduction and elimination what does
it mean how do you introduce a type
where do you get it from
meaning what are the constructors what
are the functions then return this type
okay what kind of things you need in
order to produce an element of this type
and in the in the case of unit the
introduction is trivial you don't need
anything the unit exists okay so the
introduction is trivial we'll see later
introduction and elimination rules for
other things there are more complex and
they make more sense unit is just
special okay it has no elimination
because it has no elimination means you
know what do what can you do with it
what can you how can you extract
information from it
you cannot extract information from from
unit because it has no information it
just exists okay and there is a dual to
this there is there is the well in in
logic you have false right in the false
value and it corresponds to an empty set
in set theory and a corresponds in
Haskell actually there is a type void
that corresponds to an empty set okay
it's not very useful it has no
introduction because you cannot produce
an element of an empty set because there
aren't any right
[Music]
so let's get to the next one the
interesting one products okay so where
do products come from so all these
things actually come from the way we
decompose reality and the first thing
that that we found out about composition
is I have one thing I have another thing
now I have both things okay this is like
just like so trivial right and this
corresponds to what we call a product I
mean you might think it's a son but but
no really it's it's it's it's called a
product and and again I'll start with
logic okay in logic this thing of
combining two things into one is called
conjunction a and B how do you produce a
conjunction how do you prove that a and
B is true well you have to prove a and
you have to prove B so we need two
proofs in order to prove the conjunction
right
this corresponds in programming is
corresponds to pairs so it conjunction
compares corresponds to creating a pair
of two types okay which naturally
generalized two tuples suck if you heck
have a pair you can have a triple
quadruple and so on then you want to so
these these are sort of anonymous parts
the first second third okay you can give
them names and then you have structs you
have records right in other languages it
says the data part of a class is is
these are all product types because when
you construct them you have to provide
all the ingredients right and this is
how products are defined in set theory
this is called Cartesian product
sets okay what's the introduction and
I'll write it in in in Haskell speak
okay so in order to create or construct
a pair of a and B you have to provide an
element of a and you have to provide an
element of B okay so this is like a
function that takes something of a
something of B and produces a pair a B
it's like Haskell notations is very very
concise in in C++ do you have a
definition of a pair in the standard
library and it's like eight pages long
okay this is this is what you have in
Haskell because Haskell Haskell like is
built from from the ground up it's
actually built from the theory so it's
it's not an ad hoc thing added later
okay so this is how you construct it and
notice this this parallel with logic
right in order to prove a conjunction
you need a proof of a and the proof of B
in order to construct a pair you need
the value of a and the value of type B
having a value of type a corresponds to
having a proof of this proposition a
okay so type is equivalent to a
proposition and the truth of a
proposition corresponds to having an
element an element is actually a proof
that this thing it's like we we usually
deal with types that actually have
elements right so and we can provide
elements of these types easily but but
it's not always true I mean like you can
you can define function types for
instance and if you don't have an
implementation or the implementation is
impossible then then it's an empty type
right elimination if you give me a pair
what can I do with this pair okay I the
first thing I do with the pair I can do
other stuff
later but the first thing that I can do
with the pair is extract a or I can
extract B so these are these two
functions in Haskell first takes a pair
and returns a value of of a and this is
the value that I put there in the
constructor how do I know that that it's
the same value well because in type
theory there are also these coherence
conditions which say if you construct a
pair using a and B and then you extract
the first component you'll get back a ok
so there's an additional constraint and
also if you if you give me a pair and
then I extract a and I extract B and
then I combine them together using the
introduction into a pair a B I'll get
the same pair back ok
since trivial but this is like the
coherence condition and it's enough to
define what the product is okay so if we
have products we also have sums and
unfortunately in most languages sums are
like not really supported very well it's
and they come much later in life but but
from the point of view of type theory
they're they are extremely important
they correspond to the dual to two
product and in logic there correspond to
an alternative so so this is also this
this very old primitive thing that our
ancestor already knew you know I have a
stone or I have a spear I can bring food
okay it doesn't matter whether I have a
stone or a spear as long as I can
like hunt right so this is like the
first idea of abstraction right it
doesn't really matter what tool it is as
long as it's hell
me hunting okay so this this or
something or something is reflecting
this idea of combining two things as an
alternative and in programming this is
in Haskell it's called either when you
extend this like either this or this or
this or this multiple things then you
get unions tag to unions okay
[Music]
tag unions were introduced in C++ quite
recently really I mean this hasn't been
for very long in in Haskell when you
when you do a some type like either is
the some type right you put this
vertical bar all right how much time do
I have 10 minutes okay I knew that like
okay so in set theory this is this is
called a disjoint you disjoint Union
okay so like all these things have their
parallels in in logic in programming in
set theory there is an introduction so
there are two constructors you either
give me a value of the left type or you
give me a value of the right type you
don't have to give me both okay one one
is enough
so introduction is easy elimination is
there a little bit more complicated
because you have to do pattern matching
this is what you do in you know in
Haskell in other languages I guess you
do some kind of case statements saying
is this the type or is that the type and
so on what is important here is that if
you do pattern matching that you have to
take into account that it could be of
type a or it could be of type B you
don't know up front somebody gives you
a value of of a some type you have to be
prepared for both so in order to process
it you really need two different
functions okay so you need a pair of
functions to process some of types okay
so there is this nice duality okay so
since I don't have much time I'll just
I'll just tell you that there is there
is also Exponential's right which
correspond and this is the interesting
part because they correspond in logic to
implication if I have an A then I can
produce B if you give me a proof of a I
can take this proof manipulated
manipulated and I get a proof of B okay
so this manipulation of a proof of a
corresponds in programming to functions
okay so here here's an example of
manipulation of office of an logical
things like if I have a and B and C then
I have I can prove a and B and C and so
on right so the the idea of exponents or
implication or is translated into
programming as functions so you have
function types ok function types and and
also I mean every every programming
language has functions really but no
this first-class citizens this is like a
recent thing that they added lambdas to
to Java for instance right I mean years
a few years right so treating all
functions as first-class citizens just
like pairs and and either's and unions
right it's it's but it's it means that
if if you have a type of a function it
means that you can create a function
that takes this type as an argument or
returns this type as an argument so it
makes functions first-class citizens
okay and and here here is like the proof
of this statement in logic is translated
into a function that takes an X is if
which is of this type a and B and C and
just takes first the first second the
first second and so on right so so
implementing this function is the same
as the proof of this statement okay
anytime you implement the function in
your language you are proving a
statement okay so you are doing logic so
that I keep saying you know we
programmers are mathematicians and this
is the proof okay so in set theory you
know we have like a set of functions
between two sets set of functions
between two sets and the introduction is
through a lambda okay so this is like
the lambda in in Haskell but you now
have lambda in almost every language
right and the elimination is well okay
the elimination is by just applying this
function right so you just applied you
you provide the argument which is like
providing the proof of X of the of a
right and you get a value of type B
which is a proof of B right okay
elimination evaluations whose function
application in high school it's very
simple okay so I'm gonna quickly skip
through the rest
and just give you a little taste of like
this is really really algebra so you you
know you you have like one times a
equals a there's an algebraic equation
like can you translate it in two types
one is unit a is type a you know so
that's the proof in in in Haskell right
it's a pair product is a pair of unit
and a is the same as a not exactly the
same but it's like you can get one from
another another from so they are
isomorphic you know you can do with
Exponential's it's much nicer because
you have these these these translates
you do function types this one says a
function from a some type is a is a pair
of functions that's what I showed you
when when we did pattern matching right
yeah so that's that's Haskell notation
for this statement in particular a
square is like a function from a boolean
to a which is a pair of values one for
false ones for one for true right and
and the last one is the interesting one
because in Haskell it's it corresponds
to currying right a function from a pair
which is a function of two arguments is
the same as a function that returns a
function so it's called Carine and it's
just as this algebraic equation okay and
once you have the algebra then you can
define functions so here's the function
tada okay I put capital lambda because
there's a functional types okay so it
takes a type A and produces one plus a
okay because now I can do algebra okay
what is this it's a maybe
one corresponds to this constructor
nothing which is just a unit right
because it does not require anything and
it has only one value and a constructor
called just it just keeps a right so
this is how we produce maybe you know
this is called the type constructor and
and it has two data constructors nothing
and just so given the algebra of types
I can now produce functional functions
on types and functions on types are the
the necessary ingredient for generic
programming right this is what we
started with the idea that that we need
function some types and having algebraic
types okay I'm not gonna go through this
but you can like generalize the stuff to
infinite products infinite sums which
are which are these existential types
all this this is all really fascinating
stuff and I'm gonna tease you yeah
existential types and then of course you
need recursion right and recursion is
just the advantage of recursion is that
you get a Turing complete language you
pay a price for it
which is that you get non terminating
functions right because a recursive
function can go on forever right but
recursive types correspond to to having
definitions that that require that or so
algebraic equations but you have to
solve them okay because they have your
variable on both sides I guess define L
of a as 1 plus a times L of a this is a
definition of a list
okay tada
right it's a recursive definition but it
follows you know the same the same idea
of doing algebra okay and here's the
conclusion okay so what would you what's
important to know is that there is a
very strong foundation for types there
is type theory and if you are going
afterwards you know and and try to
invent your own language like every
programmer at some point in their own
language you know please start by
studying type theory so that you don't
have to like add things later on and say
well okay I didn't think about this I
didn't think about that and my users are
just complaining complaining and so on
right generic programming is programming
with types okay so you have to abstract
over types and and the main tool is like
when you want to construct new types
that depend on other types you need to
define functions on types okay in order
to define functions own on type C you
have to be able to create expressions to
be the right-hand sides of these
functions or bodies of these functions
right so in order to create expressions
you need some kind of algebra of types
and this is very well theoretically
founded the the algebra of types is very
well founded and then of course you as
you progress you you get into these
recursive types and they are just like
higher order algebra when you actually
try to solve equations right that you
can write having the algebra of types
you can write equations and you can
solve them solving equations really
means finding a fixed point for
give an equation that's a completely
separate topic for for another talk and
and finally once you have this figured
out how to create types using algebra
and using recursion then you can write
your generic algorithms which are just
polymorphic functions they'll operate on
these generic types okay so that's
that's all I have to say today thank you
[Applause]